for decades large companies have been
trying to dominate the online video
calling and messaging market we've seen
everything from webex msn messenger and
skype to google hangouts and zoom but it
seems like people's favorite doesn't
come from any of these large companies
rather their top choice is often discord
this is quite ironic given that projects
like google hangouts and skype have
billions of dollars behind them and
thousands of employees
after all microsoft literally spent 8.5
billion dollars just acquire skype so
clearly they take this sector quite
seriously yet they're getting crushed by
a relatively small startup that was
founded by a gamer skype does
technically have more active users
currently clocking in at 300 million
while discord only has about half of
that at 150 million but when you
consider that skype was launched in 2003
and that discord wasn't launched till
2015 it becomes clear who is really
winning the user race not to mention a
lot of skype's user base comes from
companies forcing their employees to use
skype while virtually everyone who uses
discord chooses it out of free will so
here's how a gamer showed up big tech in
one of the most saturated industries in
the world
taking a look back the story of discord
dates back to a man named jason siptron
who was born on september 21 1984 in
florida jason's interest in technology
and especially gaming started very early
on in life thanks to his father and
childhood friends
apparently jason's father was a massive
fan of technology himself and he was
always tinkering with personal computers
in his free time at the time personal
computers weren't actually all that
useful to ordinary people given that
their capabilities were extremely
limited and windows 3.1 hadn't even come
out yet nonetheless being a businessman
jason's father could see that pcs were
gonna become huge hence the constant
tinkering with pcs while jason's
father's curiosity no doubt rubbed off
on jason jason says that a lot of his
passion for tech comes from gaming and
it was actually a childhood friend that
introduced him to games apparently one
of his childhood friends owned an nes
and jason had the chance to play super
mario bros on it jason described this
experience as quote the most amazing
thing i'd ever seen in my entire life as
he grew older his love for gaming
evolved from being a player to being a
developer jason took his first computer
science class in middle school and
became friends with another coding
enthusiast within class soon after jason
hosted a sleepover for his 13th birthday
and once everyone else went to sleep
jason and his comp side friends spent
the night trying to code a role-playing
game using qbasic given that this was
their first try the game probably wasn't
that great however jason says that this
experience made it clear to him that his
career had to be related to gaming
moving forward throughout the rest of
his teenage years jason continued to be
an avid gamer some of his favorite games
include super metroid chrono trigger
earthbound uniracers street fighter
mortal kombat and most importantly a
final fantasy vi aside from gaming jason
stark uses knowledge of computers to
start earning income as a teenager jason
says that he quickly realized that most
people were relatively clueless about
computers which gave him an opportunity
to help them fix computer problems and
earn some money jason's father was
especially supportive of this endeavor
and he would regularly drive jason all
around the neighborhood so that he could
make his side hustle a reality as jason
slowly built up a reputation as a
computer prodigy people started to ask
him to do bigger tasks such as writing
code for them in fact the side hustle
grew so big that jason's parents helped
him set up a bank account and jason
started receiving wire transfers from
customers if your customers were using
wire transfers to pay you you were
clearly making big money despite this
jason didn't instantly delve into
starting a full-on development company
he says that he was intimidated of
hiring people so he preferred to keep
his side hustle a solo adventure but
with jason's ambitions it was just a
matter of time until his projects
outgrew him
moving into college jason attended for
sale university in florida presumably to
major in computer science given that
jason had been coding for several years
at this point college wasn't that
difficult for him and he would end up
graduating early after graduation jason
moved to san rafael california and
picked up a job as a console game
developer initially he got himself his
own place and lived alone but he says
that this got boring pretty quickly so
he moved into a college house and became
roommates with nine uc berkeley students
while this may seem suboptimal at first
glance this actually turned out to be
extremely valuable you see about six
months after moving into the house a man
named rohan relin moved in like jason
rohan was a software enthusiast and his
uncle and he were actually planning on
launching an incubator called uweb that
was supposed to help mobile games get
off the ground as you would guess jason
was extremely intrigued by this idea and
rohan would eventually invite jason to
join the incubator at the incubator
jason would meet another developer named
danielle casley and together they would
develop their first major mobile game
called aurora faint the game combined
two of jason's favorite genres which
were role-playing games and puzzle games
so jason was basically living his dream
of being able to work on developing a
game that really interested him as a
career
all of this took place in late 2007 and
early 2008 so apple had just released
the iphone and the app store wasn't even
a thing yet jason and danielle weren't
exactly developing the game specifically
for the iphone but once the app store
was launched it was clear to them that
they had to address the iphone market
this was actually perfect timing because
it allowed aurora fane to be one of the
first games on the app store and the
given that most of the original apps on
the app store weren't that great aurora
faint was quickly able to build up a
solid user base of over 1 million users
despite this the game wasn't very
profitable given that there was no
recurring revenue from customers apple
didn't even support in-app purchases at
the time so jason and daniella only
earned money on the upfront cost of the
game which was only one dollar at one
point jason only had two months worth of
funding left and he remembers calling
his parents and telling them that he
might need to move in with them but
luckily for jason that's when he would
come up with his best idea yet
jason's breakthrough moment came when he
was having a conversation with rohan's
uncle peter about where to take aurora
faint during this conversation jason
said that it was weird that xbox live
wasn't available on iphone given how
fast the mobile gaming market was
growing it you would think that either
microsoft or apple would have released
something similar to xbox live but this
wasn't the case and this is when rawan's
uncle realized that aurora faint already
had aspects of xbox live within it so it
wouldn't be that difficult to create
their own version of xbox live called
open faint jason didn't have any money
left though so he pitched this idea to a
few investors who agreed to fund the app
if he could prove that game developers
would support the endeavor later that
week jason posted the idea of open find
on techcrunch which resulted in hundreds
of game developers signing up and
pledging their support and with that
jason was funded and he would code like
crazy over the next several weeks and
eventually on february 17 2009 jason
would launch open faint given that there
was no native alternative and the
overwhelming support from game
developers open faint quickly caught on
amongst mobile gamers open fan's user
base grew into the tens of millions
which allowed jason to complete funding
rounds that each raised millions it
looked like things couldn't get any
better and that's exactly when apple
launched game center jason says that he
felt like the heir was being sucked out
of his lungs as he realized that he was
now competing against apple despite
jason's fears though game center
actually ended up being a massive
propellant for open paint you see here
jason integrated open feint into game
center and integrated game center into
open faint so open find users could
enjoy the benefits of game center and
the new game center users could
naturally discover openfint it was a
win-win scenario and at the peak of open
paint success they boasted 120 million
users and supported 7 000 games given
this popularity i don't think you'd be
too surprised here that gree would go on
to buy open faint for 104 million
dollars it's not clear what percentage
of open paint jason owned before the
acquisition but i think it's safe to
assume that the sale made jason a
multi-millionaire at the very least if
not a deca millionaire well jason had a
pretty nice ending the same cannot be
said about open faint around the same
time a coalition of gamers would sue
open faint for violating their privacy
and a little over a year later gre would
announce that they're shutting down open
paint due to overwhelming backlash and
that was the better end of open faint
while losing open faint was likely a
massive blow for jason and he was pretty
well off financially so he had the
luxury of taking some time off and
focusing on something else initially
jason actually turned to creating
another gaming company called hammer and
chisel in 2012. this company would
release a mobile game called fates
forever but this never really garnered
much attention disappointed by the
launch jason often spent a lot of his
time playing games like final fantasy
xiv and the league of legends one of the
first things that stuck out to him as he
played these games was that their
in-game voice communication services
were absolute garbage so jason set out
to develop a user-friendly voice
communication service that had minimal
impact on game performance and that's
how discord was founded over the next
year jason worked with euweb to develop
discord and given that he'd been a gamer
for his entire life he knew exactly what
gamers wanted jason would go on to
launch discord in may of 2015 and he
says that he didn't market it to any
specific audience but naturally one of
the first communities that started
embracing the platform were gaming
subreddits this quickly made it popular
among twitch streamers and eventually
esports and land tournament gamers one
of the first companies that saw the
potential of discord was time warner
cable who invested into the company in
late 2016. two years later microsoft
would also embrace the company by
bringing discord support to xbox live
users microsoft would actually
eventually try to buy discord for 12
billion dollars but jason would turn
down this offer in april of 2021 and
given that discord has since
successfully completed a funding round
at a 15 billion valuation it looks like
turning down the acquisition deal was
the right decision but it's not all
sunshines and rainbows ahead for discord
given that discord doesn't directly
charge any of its users the revenue per
user is likely not that great and
considering how they're constantly
completing new funding rounds it's
likely that discord is losing money this
is fine for a startup but you can only
keep up a money losing company for so
long so discord needs to focus on
monetization and profitability asap but
i think jason is well aware of that and
that's exactly what he's trying to do
so over the next couple of years it's
likely that discord only goes even
bigger and potentially even becomes the
world's largest voice communication
platform but we'll just have to wait and
see what's your favorite aspect about
discord comment that down below
also drop a like if you think that
discord blows out the competition and of
course consider checking out our
international channels to watch your
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hurry and i'll see you guys on the next
one